okay so let's begin begin class and
today we are discussing whether or not
Trump will win in November and I'm
making the prediction that he will win
in November and that he will pick Nikki
Haley as his vice
president okay so let me make you the
argument
today okay so let's first discuss why
Biden won in 2020 and why it's possible
that he may lose this year okay so in
2020 it was a very special year in
American politics because it was a large
it was the largest turnout in American
history since about
1900 okay so 74 million people voted for
Trump Biden uh for Biden 81 million
people voted for
him
and two out of every three American
adults came out to vote okay so was the
largest turnout uh in American history
um it doesn't it sounds like a very uh
lopsided victory for Biden 81 million
versus 74 million but because America
hasn't been called an electoral college
system um which is not direct democracy
actually the margin of victory was only
65,000 votes meaning that if 65 th000
people in key Battleground States flip
their votes than Trump would have won
okay so the margin of victory was very
very close as is usually the case in
highly contested American elections so
let's understand the Coalition that
brought Biden into the White House okay
so the
first uh major component of this
Coalition are black people 91% % of All
Blacks voted for Biden only 8% voted for
Trump that's a huge majority for
Biden so why did so many black people
vote vote for Biden in 2020 well first
of all it's
because Biden was Obama's vice president
for eight years and so a lot of older
black people had a certain loyalty to
him okay they felt that we owe this man
because he served loyal loyally to our
men Barack Obama for years and so so now
we must bring him into the White House
but this year the debt is paid off right
so they won't feel so loyal to Biden
okay also in
20120 there's something called a George
Floyd
protest so what happened was that um in
May 2020 a black man in Minneapolis
George Floyd
he was strangled to death by a white
police officer it was captured on video
and it caused a natural uproar in fact
um there were riots and protests
throughout the country and Trump came
out um and did not acknowledge the pain
that black people felt because of this
death and so black people felt um
antipathy towards Trump okay so these
are the two major reasons why black
people voted for Biden in
2020 but this
year uh Trump's not in office right
Biden's in office so black people are
asking the question what has Biden done
for us these past four
years and unfortunately the answer is um
not that much and in fact you can make
the
argument that
Biden has really hurt the standard of
living of black people why because
um
inflation has gone up okay when
inflation goes up um it usually hurts
poor people the most okay the of living
goes way
down also illegal
immigration has gone up okay so in 2010
2020 when Trump left office there were
about 10 million illegal immigrants in
America now there are 20 million illegal
immigrants in America and it seems like
B's doing nothing to stop
uh this trend and of course when illegal
immigrants come to the country they
usually take the jobs of poor people
okay they bring wages down and that
again hurts black people and then third
is
Ukraine so while the stand of living for
black people and other poor people in
America are going down America is
sending tens of billions of dollars to
Ukraine to fight a war that has nothing
to do with um America so many Americans
see this as black as just bad leadership
okay so that's black people uh and and
recent polls show that actually um
Biden's lead uh with black people is not
as much as it was in 2020 okay so this
this lead is going down uh young people
okay what young people tend to vote
Democratic in all
elections um and they were extremely
galv ized uh to vote in 2020 because
they saw Trump as this very hateful
racist that they must remove from office
right and they they were driven to
believe this because of the George Floyd
protest unfortunately this year young
people may not feel compelled to vote
for Biden in fact a lot of young people
are choosing to set out this election
why you guys
know Gaza okay okay so as you know right
now throughout America on college
campuses young people are protesting the
war in
Gaza um so these young people are not
going to vote for Trump but they
probably will not vote for Biden as a
protest against American policy uh VI
Israel okay now let's look at the
college educated okay so 70% of people
with college degrees voted for Biden the
these are are what we call the um
Coastal Elite right the coastal
professional uh managerial Elite and
they usually overwhelmingly vote
Democratic and this year they will still
sit the same but they will be less
enthusiastic because of what they
perceived to be poor Global Leadership
okay Biden under Biden's watch Ukraine
blew up but so did Gaza and many are
starting to feel that it's because Biden
comes across as too old too weak and too
feeble to S against Putin okay so
college educated people will still
overwhelming vote Democratic that is the
core democratic base but they'll be less
enthusiastic about Biden and they'll
vote primarily uh against Trump okay
women okay so 54% of women uh voted for
for Biden 44% voted for Trump okay and
again um because Trump is seen as this
hateful figure uh we should we expect
that woman will still consistently vote
Democratic this year okay and also
because of abortion issues right so um
women are very passionate about abortion
and they will come out and vote for
Biden to ensure that abortion rights are
protected
last look at let's look at sub Suburban
voters okay so the suburbs the suburbs
are between the cities the urban areas
and the rural areas okay cities urban
areas overwhelmingly support the
Democratic party rural areas
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly support
the Republican party so the
suburbs um are where the Battleground is
and so if you look at
19 uh sorry um
2016 when Trump defeated Hillary
Clinton only
45% of the suburbs voted for Clinton
which allowed Trump to defeat her in the
election Okay now what's interesting is
that in
2020 this flipped and
54% of uh Suburban voters voted for
Biden that's a flip of 2 million
voters okay so in elections usually it's
a Suburban vote that determines the
election because the the swing voters
okay um so for Trump to win this year he
needs to win the Suburban vote he won
that in 2016 he lost that in 2020 okay
so let's examine very
quickly um why the suburbs went Biden in
2020 okay and there are three major
reasons the first
is the media
narrative so what was happening for
out uh Trump's presidency is basically
the entire mainstream media got together
and criticize Trump okay so the first
major criticism of trump if you if you
remember is he was a Russian asset okay
he was a paid Putin puppet and of course
course that was just a complete lie what
we call rugate okay but then they start
to say that Trump was a divisive
figure okay and this
idea caught the imagination of the
suburbs okay because if you live in the
suburbs you tend to be middle class you
tend to be pretty wealthy and well
educated so you like the status quo you
want a leader who's conservative and
who's a un fire and throughout the Trump
presidency we saw the polarization of
Politics the left and the right hated
each other and they fought all the time
and what really showed this was the
George Floyd protest right so you had um
protesters rioting in the streets and
Trump was like let's send in the
military to crush the protesters and so
people in the suburbs were very worried
about this thought that a leader the
President should be a
uniter right and Biden uh came across as
extremely steady as as very
establishment as someone who could unite
both the Republican party and the
Democratic party okay that was his
perception in 2020 so that's the first
major reason why the suburbs went Biden
second um was the pandemic so as you
know Co hit the United States and the
suburbs were extremely freaked out about
this because they they T they tend have
children who go to
school um they tend to be um older and
they thought that Trump's handling of
the P pandemic was very incompetent okay
he W he he was an outsider a political
Outsider but that meant he could not get
things done in
Washington okay so that's a second uh
problem with Trump and the third reason
reason why the sub the suburbs went uh
Biden is Cal
Harris okay and this is key uh Biden
picked Kam Cala Harris to be his vice
president to be his running mate and
Kamala Harris uh let me tell you a
little about Kamala Harris her father is
Jamaican her mother is
Indian and uh she has a she has she has
a younger sister
but when she she was young her dad left
the family so her mom raised um the two
girls by
herself and um Harris is an extremely
accomplished person she went to Stanford
then then she became uh Attorney General
of California then became a US senator
okay and there are three reasons why the
suburbs love Camila Harris okay first of
all
um like us okay meaning like she comes
across as someone who
speaks and thinks like people in the
suburbs okay well educated uh articulate
smart conservative okay second is she
seemed as very
establishment meaning that she's not
liberal in fact when she was Attorney
General of C California she was
extremely tough on crime she was trying
to send as many people to jail as
possible and sometimes quite honestly
some of the of these people were
innocent okay and she still and she
still sent them to jail okay that she
was very controversial as uh attorney
general but guess what guys people in
the suburbs like tough on crime okay
they want safety they want security
because they have
kids okay and the third reason why they
like coming out here is is because of
the Redemption story
so um in
2019 there is a Democratic primary okay
this is when uh the
Democrats try to get a nomination for
the general election okay and there was
a lot of
people um who who are vying for the
nomination including Joe Biden and K
Harris in June
2019 there were there was the first
democratic debate okay not this point
Kam Harris and Joe Biden were considered
very uh heavy favorites to win the
nomination and in that first debate K
Harris and Joe Biden got into a very
nasty argument on television okay so
what happened is that K harrish turned
to Joe Biden and Joe Biden is kind of
Shell Shocked okay he's he's kind of old
and he and like Kam Harris is directing
her words at him and he doesn't really
want to see her okay Hees he doesn't
really want to confront her and um what
Kam Harris says to Joe Biden is Joe
you've been you've been in Washington DC
for 50 years and some of your policies I
don't support for example you did not
support the integration of black and
white students together well you know
what Joe I'm a black student I was a
black little girl girl gr up in the 70s
in California and I got my opportunity
to succeed in America because of
integration because I could go to white
school and you opposed my opportunity to
succeed okay so
basically um she was calling Biden a
racist and at that point everyone
thought that okay well if Biden gets a
ination there's no way he's going to
pick her to be the VP okay and
then he picks her to be the VP and so
what do people think about
Biden what what do people people think
of Biden what impression do people get
because of this
anyone yes okay exactly okay doesn't
doesn't hold grudges what
else what
else what else doesn't hold grudges he's
a very forgiving man what
else good yes he listens right he's a
listener he's a team
player okay and he has empathy okay he
understands that voters want Comm Harris
okay and guess what guys these three
things doesn't hold grudges listens team
player and empathy this is anti-trump
right this is the antitrump
and because of this narrative women
especially women in the suburbs went for
Biden okay previously they had gone for
Trump now they they went for Biden
because as it turns out women want um
compassionate empathetic leadership that
is the decisive and
bold but um is
also um tolerant okay and that this is
also why even though Hillary Clinton
like ran in 2016 and she was a woman the
suburbs didn't vote for her because she
was she didn't come across as someone
who was compassionate and forgiving and
tolerant okay does that make sense and
this is
why uh Biden was able to win in in
so this year what can Trump do to win
the
suburbs what can he
do yeah he can copy this exact same
thing okay and it turns out he can do
this okay why
because uh on the Republican side
there's someone called Nikki ke Nikki
Kelly oh sorry Nikki haly
and Nikki Haley is very similar to cala
Harris okay Nikki
Haley her parents are Indian immigrants
okay so she's Indian she's of South
Asian uh uh
descent and her family was not very
wealthy but she worked hard and she
became Cal she became South Carolina
governor for two two for two terms and
then she joined the Trump Administration
as un Ambassador in
2016 Okay now what's interesting about
Nikki Haley is
that Nicki Hy ran against Trump in the
Republican primary
okay and even though she lost to Trump
there was a group of people who loved
her guess who just loved her who voted
for her in droves guess guess what what
demographic group
anyone Suburban woman okay do you
understand college educated Suburban
woman okay so in other
words if Trump brings her on to the
ticket then it's very likely he can
swing the suburbs back to him and win
the election but there's a problem the
problem is that Nikki Haley and Trump
got into a very nasty fight during the
primary okay so Nikki Haley said listen
I served under Trump and I think he's
he's a divisive figure and right now in
our country we we need a unifier that's
why I'm running for president because I
want to unite this country whereas Trump
will can only divide this country okay
and then Trump being Trump responds and
says Nikki haly is a bird brain she's
stupid okay
so you think you you see this you think
like there's no way Trump will pick her
because Nick H is not loyal to Trump
right and Trump likes loyalty also hey
guys Trump holds grudges right and he
doesn't listen and he's not a team
player and he lacks empathy so there's
no way he would pick Nikki Haley and in
fact um this past week there's there's
been new news report that Nikki Haley is
in consideration to be Trump's vice
president and Trump came out and said I
am not considering Nicki Hy okay but let
me ask you this
question if in August during the
Republic Republican convention he does
pick Nicki
heli how would people feel about him
how would the media report
this Nikki Haley is an enemy of Trump
trump called her a bird brain Trump said
I will never pick Nikki Hy and then in
August uh three months from now he says
you know what I was wrong I think Nicki
Hy is the best person to be my VP that's
why she'll be my running mate in
November how people feel about
him what what would the suburbs think
about
Trump how would you feel if you saw
this he's a changed
man
right Trump has grown remember like the
narrative about Trump is he is a
5-year-old child and remember like
people were like don't insult 5-year-old
CH children like that okay 5-year-old
children are much more mature than Trump
so the argument about Trump is he he's
divisive but much more than that he's
immature he's incapable of growth okay
but hey if in August he picks Nikki
hilly to be his VP then the media will
be like he is a changed man he's learned
his lessons he's willing to let go of
grudges he's willing to listen he now
has
empathy therefore he should be president
okay do you
understand the then what happens is the
suburbs switch over to Trump and then he
wins so if he picks Nicki Haley in
August he will win okay I'm not
completely sure that he will pick Nikki
haly I think that this is his best
strategic move okay but Trump is not
really predictable
all right and who he picks as vice
president will give us a good clue as to
how he will govern when he be when he
becomes president okay does that make
sense all right now the question then is
okay who is Nikki haly and what will she
do as vice president Okay now what's
important to understand about Nikki
Haley is that when she left office when
she left Washington DC Poli office in in
2018 she had nothing in her bank account
okay she had no money in her bank
account now she has $1 million in her
bank account and she lives in a $5
million
mansion so where did she get this money
okay she got her she got this money
mainly for an organization called
United
against a
nuclear
Iran okay and this
organization's primary purpose is to
create conflict between United States
and
Iran okay they they go against any
companies or individuals who support
Iran United States who does business
with Iran okay they are a very
anti-iranian
uh
organization one their main donors his
name is
Sheldon
elderson and Sheldon elderson is an
extremely
pro-israel business
person okay he he owns a lot a lot of
casinos okay so MGM SS uh he's he's a
billionaire and what's interesting about
sandel uh sandal elderson he's dead okay
but he was the main patron of of a man
named Benjamin
nanyu okay he is the main political
Patron and financial donor to Benjamin
nanyu so Sheldon Ellison supports both
nanyu and supports this organization
called United against a nuclear Iran and
United against a nuclear Iran
hired um Nikki haly and paid her a lot
of money okay that's the first thing
second thing is is that in 2019 she got
a job of
Boeing Boeing is a weapons manufacturer
they make airplanes but they mainly make
bombs and missiles okay so they love war
she sat on the board of Boeing a
extremely prestigious job and she was
paid
$300,000 just to sit on the board and do
nothing okay she has also given speeches
at an organization called
Christians United for
Israel and you may remember that this is
a 7
million strong organization that
supports war in the Middle East they are
evangelic Christians they are
dispensation um premillennialists who
believe that war between Israel and Iran
will bring Jesus back to Earth Earth and
establish the kingdom of heaven and
therefore they want as much conflict in
the Middle East as possible okay so all
this is telling us is that if nikii
becomes vice
president her main
responsibility will be to agitate for
war against Iran okay she'll be the one
in the white house pushing for war in
Iran escalating tensions in Iran
okay
so Nikki Hy okay what's also interesting
is okay in January
2019 basically the primary is over Trump
has won everything okay but in January
2019 even after Trump won Haley was able
to raise more money than Trump so Haley
got about $12 million
from donors Trump gets got1 million
okay and the only explanation for this
is these donors knew that hilly would
not become president she could not be
Trump but they were trying to position
her to be his vice president by making
her uh stay in the race and giving her
as much publicity as possible in fact
even though she dropped out the race
she's still getting about um 25% to 33%
of all Republican votes
okay so she comes across as an extremely
popular establishment
figure okay so does does this make sense
okay so the conclusion is
that
given um the way the situation in the
United States it seems very likely Trump
will win in 2024 okay because the Biden
Coalition will not pull together because
of inflation illegal immigration what's
happening in Gaza what's happening in
Ukraine Trump looks very strong right
now and the poll suggests that either
the race is tied between the two or
Trump has slight Advantage
okay Trump can basically seal the
victory if he picks Nikki Haley to be
his vice
president because Nicki haly will turn
the suburbs to him
very strongly and it's a suburbs that
basically decide uh us
elections and as vice president what she
will be doing is agitating for war
against Iran which means that she's on
the
payroll of anti-iranian
forces in the United
States
okay so any question questions anything
you're not clear about right
now okay so Jack asked a great question
okay he's like what if Haley holds a
grudge and says no right
um and quite honestly she has been asked
in the past are you willing to serve as
Trump's vice president and she's like no
because he's a divider he's divisive and
we need to move on from Trump okay all
right um do you guys
remember um in class when we studied
Trump very closely his personality we
looked at his days in the
WWWE okay and there was a scene where V
Vince McMahon the owner of WWE a
billionaire challenges Trump to a fight
right well guess what guys politics is
the same thing it's all theater okay
politics is
theater what Nicki Haley and Donald
Trump are doing is pretending to be
bitter enemies so that so that their
reconciliation
will be so
dramatic you understand um so Nicki Hy
served under Trump in the first
Administration okay so from 2016 to 2018
she was UN Ambassador for
Trump and everyone says that the two got
along really well in fact um Trump was
considering having her be his VP running
made in 2020 he was speaking of dropping
Pence and putting her on the ticket okay
so the two of them together actually
have a great Rapport the two respect
each other they get along very well okay
so that's the first thing second thing
is that the thing to know about very
successful politicians
is they are first and foremost
opportunists they have no
ideas they have no
principles all they care about is
political power right so why would Nicki
Haley agree to be vice
president
why because it's one step away from the
presidency do you understand if anything
happens to Trump she's president and in
four years time she can run
as the Republican nominee for the
presidency okay does that make sense
okay so that's a thing you you need to
know about politicians okay all they
care care about is political power they
would do anything
to achieve polical power they will they
will sell their own mother okay to
achieve polical power but that's the
same thing for rich people okay rich
people love money they will do anything
to get money okay sell their own mother
fine okay you understand also
celebrities famous people right all they
care about is
Fame okay so do you understand Jack all
right any more questions
I is this clear to you guys
uh is there anything you're not clear
about I I I'll explain
further okay so um Jack asked a great
question okay well listen like
I can figure this out just by reading
the news right Biden has an amazing team
of extremely well-paid professional
experience strategist working with him
they know this they can see what's going
on so what can Buton do to counter
Trump's strategy or the polls okay and
the answer is this um if you look at
2020 everyone thought that
Biden uh could not get the nomination
okay why because he lacks Charisma no
one really likes him okay so when Biden
goes to speak there's no one there to
listen to him he's
boring um and he has no ideas and he's
old I mean Biden ran for president two
times before and he lost both times and
the reason why is he's not charismatic
and he has no
ideas okay but Biden's like nope I'm
going to stay in the race because I
believe I can win and and you ask him
Biden what is your strategy what is your
reasoning going forward I don't know I'm
gonna win
okay um so if we were discussing this in
2020 in May and June I would be
like Biden has no chance okay because
Trump's GNA go out there and give
speeches to a 100,000 people and they're
gonna love him and they're gonna
go and vote for him okay Biden gives a
speech everyone falls
asleep and on the debate stage Trump
will destroy Biden
okay so I was sure that in May April
2020 Biden had no chance but then what
happened hey the George Floyd protest
happened so all these young people who
didn't really like Biden they were now
galvanized to go vote vote for him all
these black people all these Suburban
voters they wanted Biden to win because
they thought Trump was divisive okay and
then what happened the pandemic happened
so Trump couldn't go out to debate they
Trump couldn't go out to campaign
anymore you understand Biden could just
sit in his basement and do
nothing right do you understand so
unfortunately Biden learned the wrong
lessons from 2020 the lesson that he
learned in 2020 is that hey if I just
sit in my basement all day and make no
mistakes my surrogates the Democratic
party will Hillary Clinton Bill Clinton
Barack Obama they'll go out and give
speeches for me they'll fire up the base
and I'll win because I'm not Trump okay
that is the entire B strategy I'm not
Trum okay the problem with this idea is
okay um in 2020 the American people had
four years of trump and they know he
sucks okay the problem now is the
American people have seen four years of
Biden and Biden sucks as well okay and
so it's a question like who sucks more
Biden or Trump okay so in other words
people are not going to come out to vote
because they think both
suck and which means that the party with
a coalition with a base that feels more
strongly about the issues is going to
come out to vote okay and what we know
is
that the Republican Coalition of rural
voters conservatives
Christians um white voters they feel
much more passionate about Trump then
the Democratic Coalition feels about
Biden okay does that make sense so
unfortunately the answer is that Biden
has no strategy going forward because he
didn't have a strategy going forward in
2020 and he won in 2020 so why can't the
same thing happen
in same happened this year
right and unfortunately because Biden is
so old he's 81 he doesn't have the
energy to change the way he is you
understand it's much easier for him to
sit around and
pray that I'm not Trump will deliver
another election than it is for him to
go out and change who he is he can't
change who he is
okay does that make sense okay but but
that's a great question all
right any any
more um
questions before
okay so again I am not sure who will win
this year okay I think it's Trump I'm
not sure that Nikki Haley will be his
vice president I'm just making a guess
so then then the question then is why
are we doing this and the answer is this
we try to think we have to build an
analytical model right of how the world
works and the only way we know if this
model works or not is by making
predictions and testing it against
reality okay so you know what it's
possible that in
August um Trump will pick someone else
okay possibly someone named JD Vance
okay um the only thing you need you need
to know about J vent is he's very loyal
to Trump okay it's possible he picks he
picks JD vents okay I think he'll pick
Nicki Hy I often actually um
I often think that there's a very good
chance he picks JD v as well okay but I
but but I'll make the bet that he picks
Nikki Hy okay so it's possible in August
he does not pick Nicki Nicki H picks
shie Vance or someone else instead okay
it's also possible that in November
Trump
loses okay but that's fine because
because if if I'm wrong then what I do
is I go back to this analysis and I make
changes to anal this analysis so so that
it's much more reflective and accurate
okay does that make
sense okay and and that's how we try to
think critically about the World by
building an an models that we can then
test against reality and then ba and
then based on what happens in reality we
can go and refine our anical model right
any any
questions Okay so next
week um we discuss the war in Iran okay
because if you look at uh this again if
Nikki Haley becomes the uh vice
president it is very likely she will
agitate for War uh against Iran uh and
Trump will go along okay and if that's
the case then we we need to understand
how America will fight the war and how
Iran will respond and that's what what
we will we will do next week okay